bienvenue à cette table c'est moi qui
mner le jeu ce
soir le gagnant
tout
deou millions sur la
table
je
j'ai envie de m'amuser ce soir
j'augmente les
enchères les voitures ou les jetons de
poker tu es sérieux il y a 5 millions
chacun je vous les
offre ça s trenard si vous
abandonnez il y aura pas de retour
possible lecture des volontés
testamentaires mourir est inéluctable le
vivant est voué à mourir ma fille va
passer S rouleau compresseur mais je ne
peux rien y faire j'ai une liaison va
pas à la maison ce soir on change de
plan on ne change rien du tout non non
non non non hors de question de faire ça
ce soir tu piges il sera
là pour ce soir tout est organisé je
relance de 2 millions
[Musique]
Olin salut
Jack on veut de mal à personne on veut
desr c'est encore une de tes surprises
Jack le
tableau j'ai J
[Musique]
l'b je veux
J
les deux autres m'intéressent
pas